madame monsieur chers amis la page de la
présidentielle est tournée nous voilà
engagé dans la campagne des législatives
inscrivez votre calendrier le 12 et 19
juin prochains vous voterez pour élire
votre député depuis 20 ans jean pierre
door est votre député jean pierre est un
homme profondément attaché à son
territoire il l'a défendu à paris et a
été reconnu comme un des parlementaires
très engagé sur les sujets de santé et
les affaires sociales il y a près d'un
an jean piat m'a proposé d'être candidat
à sa succession
j'ai accepté cet honneur avec dans
l'idée d'être comme lui un député utile
utile à son territoire notre gastines et
qui a de grandes ressources mais qui
doit se battre pour faire passe pour
force à ceux qui rentrent des métropoles
d'orléans et de paris nous avons besoin
d'entreprises pour utiliser notre force
de travail nous avons besoin d'un revenu
décembre nos agriculteurs qui
nourrissent au quotidien nos veines nous
avons besoin de médecins pour conforter
nos pôles de santé à travers mon métier
l'accompagnement d'entreprises dans leur
développement et de mots mandat
départemental en charge de développement
économique je connais le monde du
travail et le tissu économique je serai
le mieux placé pour trouver des
solutions et des moyens pour nos villes
et nos villages utile aussi à son pays
la france a subi depuis cinq ans de
multiples fractures
l'écart s'est creusé entre ceux qui nous
dirigent à paris et la france des
régions et des territoires pour éviter
de voir d'une nouvelle crise des gilet
jaune voire une explosion sociale il
faut renouer le dialogue entre nos
gouvernants et les gouvernés cela
passera nécessairement par la
décentralisation c'est à dire donner
plus de pouvoir aux élus locaux et
réduire les normes et les règles qui tue
toute initiative
les bonnes idées doit pouvoir être
exprimés élu député je m'engagerai
totalement dans ce combat pour la
décentralisation car c'est la seule voie
possible pour que notre pays sorte de
langue d'ici là je continuerai d'aller à
votre rencontre
comme je le fais depuis des mois j'en
suis convaincu
ensemble nous irons plus loin je veux
travailler main dans la main avec la
région le département du loiret les
maires du gâtinais les acteurs
économiques et les acteurs associatifs
avec un seul objectif vous être utile